hi I'm Thomas Burton 9090 world cup
winner no wrong I am Thomas Bertold 9090
world cup winner he gotta be kidding me
don't listen to him I'm Thomas person I
give him a we click take on the
bundesliga wrong again I give you my
weekly take on the Bundesliga we have a
special weekend with two top games yes
there he is right Club park vs Bayern
and war spoke vs Dortmund all top four
of the league play each other oh what a
party klappa vs bayern this is a
no-brainer nobody can beat by them they
smashed their opponents in 13 or 14
matches this season so far next club
path my friend you said what you think
you are wrong my friend they have one or
matches just two drawers under the new
head coach and they should they gonna
beat by an how buyin is the best team in
the world maybe barcelona on a good day
has a chance against the masters of
football [ __ ] klappa will be easy peasy
for them my friend not it is Clapperton
they are on the road last weekend they
came back two goals down they have the
players they feel the confidence and
it's a momentum they are invincible do
you think what euro is not prepared by
and did always performed very well
against the best teams 51 against walls
book 51 against top one
my friend the days of Club are numbered
give me one reason why not come on
somebody must beat Bayern they play at
home and they gonna give them a nice
Christmas gift yeah yeah yeah let's ask
the viewers okay let's ask our viewers
who is going to win whose trick come to
an end bayan klappa tell us on Facebook
I go for clapper and while you are added
tell us who is going to win the war
spoke top one match of course dodman no
worse book please drop us a line on
facebook see you next time no I see you
next time we see you on the next time